began the show talking about the
increasing trend of AI replacing human
jobs in many sectors especially in the
realm of digital media and as I said I
find this to be a generally negative
development for mankind at the same time
of course I certainly acknowledge that
in terms of the quality of the product
replacing most journalists with AI would
be a lateral move if not an improvement
and what's more many of these people
richly deserve the disgrace of not only
losing their jobs but having their
positions taken over by chat bots in
fact some of these people deserve to
lose their current jobs and all future
jobs and end up on the street bankrupt
and homeless it doesn't apply to
everybody in media but it does apply to
many of them including all of the sewer
dwelling trolls who work at the
worthless gossip mongering tabloid
called Dead spin now this week dead spin
ostensibly a sports news site decided to
help Jin up an outrage mob to go after a
child who committed the crime of wearing
a costume to a football game the kid was
in the stands to watch the City Chiefs
take on the Las Vegas Raiders on Sunday
and being apparently a Chiefs fan he
came adorned in an Indian headdress and
face paint now unfortunately for the kid
CBS which certainly knew exactly what it
was doing decided to briefly show him
this kid on camera during its coverage
of the game and here's the angle that
made it on the broadcast there it is
now as you can see it is a side profile
of the kid with his headdress and what
appears to be black face paint now you
look at that picture and there are a few
ways that you could possibly interpret
it you could assume that his entire face
is Painted Black just because he's a kid
and that's how he wanted to paint his
face because he thought it would look
cool or whatever or you could assume
that the other side of his face was
probably painted a different color or
this is all part of some design and you
can't see it because you only see the
one side of his face or better still you
could assume nothing at all and think
think nothing of it because it's just
some kid at a football game wearing a
costume and it really doesn't matter
what he's wearing or why he's wearing it
or maybe you could arrive at some
combination of these conclusions but if
you are uh idiotic and soulless and
bored and looking for reasons to be
upset about things that don't matter in
the slightest then you'll skip over all
of those possibilities and immediately
conclude that the child is a racist
wearing black face in order to mock
black
people now of course even if this was
true I would still refer you back to
option three it doesn't matter who cares
he's a kid but as it happens however it
is not true other photos taken at the
game show that his face paint is both
black and red matching his jersey and
shirt combination as you can clearly see
here now it would not be national news
if he was be wearing black face but
obviously
he's not wearing black face any rational
person would know that automatically
without needing photographic evidence to
prove it because any rational person
knows that no parent in existence would
say to his child hey let's put on
blackface to mock black people and then
go to a football game and destroy our
lives
together this is not a thing that would
ever happen or has ever happened and if
you aren't smart enough to realize that
well we have the photographic evidence
so that should be the end of
it but we know that evidence doesn't
matter to the leftist Mob which quickly
formed on social media condemning not
only the child for his alleged blackface
but uh also the Kansas City Chiefs for
not I guess grabbing him by the collar
and throwing him out of the stadium
something that would have been hard for
them to do by the way given that this
was a road game but pretty soon the
Goblins over a dead spin were on the
case an article written on Monday by
Karan Phillips has this headline the NFL
needs to speak out against the Kansas
City Chiefs fan in blackface and Native
headdress now just to be perfectly clear
here Phillips is calling on a
multi-billion dollar Corporation to
publicly rebuke an adolescent
child and it gets even more deranged and
somehow Dumber reading on it says quote
it takes a lot to disrespect two groups
of people at once but on Sunday
afternoon in Las Vegas a Kansas City
Chiefs fan found a way to hate black
people and Native Americans at the same
time I want to pause here just for a
moment it takes a lot to disrespect two
groups of people at
once he says not to belabor the point
but this is exactly the kind of feeble
inan writing that makes someone like
Kuran Phillips wholly replaceable by AI
he might actually be AI for all we know
and by the way it does not take much
effort at all to disrespect two groups
at once like I could do it easily I do
it all the time so I might I might say
something like for example Karan
Phillips has the IQ of a seahorse
thereby quite effortlessly disrespecting
both kran Phillips and seahorses it's
not hard to do doesn't take much now for
the record I am not actually officially
claiming that Phillips does have the IQ
of a seahorse according to the way that
YouTube enforces its rules these days
that might count as dehumanizing so I'm
not saying that all I can say is that
Phillips may be as dumb as a seahorse or
he may be Dumber it's also possible
technically that he could be smarter
than a seahorse he could be the only one
at dead spin who is smarter than a
seahorse I don't know I mean Phillips
could be the smartest guy over at dead
spin for all we know this could be like
Dead spin's version of Goodwill Hunting
maybe while the rest of the staff is
sitting around eating paint chips he's
standing in front of a chalkboard and
pressing them all with complicated math
equations like 3 * 3 equals
11 I don't know for sure diversify your
savings with physical pressure ious
medals while stockpiling silver in your
home safe with Birch gold group's most
popular special of the year now through
December 22nd for every $5,000 you spend
with Burch gold they'll send you a 1 o
Silver Eagle Coin for free text Walsh to
9898 98 to claim your eligibility now
you can purchase gold and silver and
have it shipped directly to your home or
have Birch Gold's precious metal
specials help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
gold for no money out of pocket and
they'll send you free for every $5,000
you purchase keep it for yourself or
give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword Walsh to 9898 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with a
better Better Business Bureau and
thousands of happy customers now is the
best time to buy gold from Birch gold
text Walsh to 9898 98 and claim your
eligibility for free silver on
qualifying purchases before December
22nd that's Walsh to 98 9898 you know
keeping your windshields clean is always
a pain the dirt piles up and washer
fluid just can't get the job done that's
where my friends at windshield wow come
in to save the day windshield wow is an
Innovative windshield cleaning device
that uses two magnetic cleaning paddles
one on the outside and one on the inside
of your car to clean both sides of your
windshield all from the outside all you
do is push around the outside paddle and
the inside follows automatically leaving
your windshield squeaky clean here in
Nashville and many parts of the country
we're starting to get a lot of rain and
with that you get this hazy and dirty
windshield well throw one of these uh in
the back of your car so you can always
have a clean windshield I personally own
a windshield wow and being able to clean
both the front and inside uh window at
the same time is a real GameChanger the
windshield wow applies firm cleaning
pressure and is super thin to get into
those tight dashboard areas what are you
waiting for go to windshield wow.com use
code Walsh a check out for a special
discount that's windshield wow.com and
use code
Walsh anyway he continues uh the image
of a Chiefs fan in blackface wearing a
native headdress during a road game
leads to so many unanswered questions
why did the camera person give this fan
the attention why did the producer allow
that camera angle to be aired at all is
that fan a kid teenager or a young adult
despite their age who taught that person
that what they were wearing was
appropriate the answer to all those
questions lead back to the
NFL well wait a second again entirely
leaving aside the fact that Phillips is
defaming this small child with a
completely fabricated claim of blackface
we're still struck by the vacuousness of
his writing how does a question like is
that fan a kid or young adult lead back
to the NFL how is the NFL responsible
for the age of the child what the hell
is Phillips babbling about now all I can
guess is that he realizes that he can't
get an entire article out of libeling
this kid with an easily disproven
allegation of blackface so instead he's
trying to make the leap from smearing
the child to accusing the NFL of
systemic racism and this was his way of
doing it and once he's made that
transition he continues quote there's no
place for a franchise to be called the
Chiefs in a league that's already
eradicated Redskins quote there's no
pretty way to mascot people Amanda
Blackhorse a Native American activist
and an organizer of a pregame protest
rally told USA Today sports earlier this
year this is what happens when you ban
books stand against critical race Theory
and try to erase centuries of hate you
give future Generations the ammunition
they need to evolve and recreate racism
better than before
recreate racism better than
before what so he's not only falsely
accusing this kid of wearing black face
to a football game but he's also
claiming that the child is perpetrating
some kind of sophisticated highly
evolved new type of racism which I guess
is true in a way it is a new type of
racism in the sense that like most other
modern examples of racism it doesn't
exist yet there is one type of racism
that has become significantly more
prevalent in recent years it's the type
that Phillips himself is engaging in
right now as we all know the only real
crime that this young fan committed was
the crime of being white if he was
anything but white the ghouls at dead
Spin and the rest of the outrage mob
would leave him
alone they picked him because he's an
easy target and he's an easy target
because he he's an unsuspecting white
kid just trying to enjoy his time at a
football
game and we can only hope that the
child's family has the resources and
wherewithal to fight back and that would
mean suing both Kuran Philips and dead
spin into bankruptcy which is what they
deserve make them suffer enormous
financial hardship as punishment for
this
defamation Force these people for once
in their miserable lives to suffer a
real consequence for their
actions we can only hope that's what
happens next
in the
meantime we of course must say that
kurran Phillips and dead spin are both
today cancelled if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there God speed